hey youtubers is charlie so this is
going to be my first daredevil season 2
video there are a couple likely story
lines that I think they're going to
explore like the hand versus the chaste
the origin story for Electra some more
backstory on Karen page so this is going
to be a breakdown all that stuff just
like Steven denied did with daredevil
season 1 they're probably gonna pull a
bunch of different comic book stories
are elements from different stories and
use them to create something new like
daredevil season 1 borrows a lot of
inspiration from Frank Miller's Man
Without Fear and from daredevil yellow
which are actually both origin stories
if you haven't read either those you
should totally check them out electrode
is a big part of Man Without Fear and
she actually starts out as something of
an antagonist she's one of those
characters when they introduce her I
hope she starts out you know fighting
Matt Murdock and then slowly over time
she becomes a hero starts working with
him she's bounced back and forth between
the hand and the chased in the comics so
she's just a little bit more fun when
she's not like absolutely good or
absolutely evil they'll also be like a
new mid-level boss you know someone for
daredevil to kick the out of on his
way to the big boss and that'll just
depend on whichever big villain group
they go with of all the non kingpin
villains that they teased in daredevil
season 1 you have your Madame Gao in the
hand Madame Gao is more of an immortal
iron fist character so I think they're
going to save her for that series there
were so many teasers during that stick
episode for chase mythology that it
makes sense that they would try to
explore that in season 2 even though
there's going to be new showrunners
there's a couple really big things they
have to address in season 2 regardless
of which storyline they go with they
have to explain what the shadow war is
that's going on between the chased in
the hand they have to explain both those
groups to they have to address what
kingpin is going to do while he's in
prison and whether or not he's going to
stay in prison for the duration of the
season even if he's stuck in that cell
he can still be just as big a villain
that's part of the magic of being
kingpin he's powerful even when he's
behind bars they have to explore Karen
pages mysterious past she has a really
infamous father in the comics way way
back during issues 56 and 57 she
actually she goes back to visit her
family home and finds out that her
father has become death's-head not this
death said this death said I know it
gets confusing there's like a number of
people that have used the name death
head in the Marvel Comics his name is
dr. Paxton page but he becomes a big
villain for a brief period born again is
one of the bigger Frank Miller Karen
page story lines but in it he treats her
in just the worst possible way so I
don't see them doing a literal
adaptation of born again it's a great
matt murdock story though it's all about
kingpin finding out that Matt Murdock is
the daredevil and tries to
systematically tear down his life and
everyone around him Karen page just gets
caught up in that just to give you an
idea like think about Karen page in
daredevil season one and then imagine
that character quitting team daredevil
to go to Mexico to become a
heroin-addicted porn star yeah they're
definitely not going to be doing that
the reason kingpin found out Daredevils
identity in that storyline is because
Karen page was looking for money and
sold out his identity to the highest
bidder so you can see that's pretty
terrible I love the idea of Karen having
a really troubled past and them
exploring it but I think that she is
going to be staying on Team daredevil
for a long time they're not going to
break the team up right after putting it
together Daredevils identity getting out
that's actually a pretty logical place
to go season 2 of the show will be
released right around the time captain
america civil war comes out in theaters
a big part of that movie is going to be
people with powers the government
finding out who they are figuring out
what they're gonna do with them
thematically you have like the human
based story so you have Matt Murdock's
identity Karen pages past then you have
like the more mystical elements that
they'll probably start weaving in you
know hand versus chased demonic
possession I don't expect to see hell
spawn Matt Murdock at any time soon he
had a demonic doppelganger during the
fall from grace storyline that he had to
battle I could imagine a version to that
storyline though the fall from grace
storyline just because it involves Matt
Murdock trying to stop a virus from
getting out it's a psychic virus so they
might they might twist that aspect just
a little bit but you get the idea to
know Matt Murdock battling his own inner
demons even though him literally
battling his demons is a little more
comic booky than I think they're gonna
go daredevil you know at its core is
still going to be crime drama so you
know as craziest things get in the
Marvel Universe I think they'll try to
keep it as grounded as possible so if
they do like a big hand storyline and
they do Elektra karegi is a big electro
villain so they might do him he's
immortal in the comics but obviously you
know you don't have to do crazy makeup
for him he can still look like a human
there's also characters like Gorgon they
could do you know other hand based
characters there was even a period
during the Shadowland comics where
kingpin took over the hand and used them
to retain the statuses crime boss in New
York kingpin has to get out of that jail
somehow and you know daredevil season
one big origin story for the kingpin as
much as it was for daredevil they have
confirmed a few things about the season
to cast you know which kind of gives you
an idea of which characters are going to
focus on so rosario Dawson is coming
back as well as all the main characters
that means it will price eclair temple
take on more of her role as night nurse
helping out other vigilantes beyond
daredevil so she'll probably don't
expand her operation her extracurricular
activities but just looking at the
amount of room they have in 13 episodes
to explore characters in a really
meaningful way I think there's only room
for like one new big hero and that's why
I'm hoping Electra comes in and everyone
wants to see bullseye but I just feel
like electro would be more fun because
she could start as a villain and then by
the end of the series she could be a
hero you just you see how like so many
elements from the hand organization work
with Electra's character kingpin and
daredevil without having to add like a
whole bunch of other characters the hand
the chase and daredevil between them all
try to get their hands on a bio weapon
like like in fall from grace and while
that's going on the hand tries to
destroy the chaste team daredevil of
course getting caught up in everything
you know with you know maybe like Karen
pages family having ties to some villain
organization one of the better
limitations of TV series which I
actually think is a good thing is that
all the elements all the characters have
to you know kind of converge on each
other by the end of the season like if
you do a Karen page story line and her
father is des head he just can't go off
in his own direction and just you know
kind of trail off into the distance that
has to loop back in on whatever's going
on with the hand and the chase as well
as daredevil in the kingpin so even if
we do get a character like Elektra like
a really big character they'll probably
only spend like an episode or two
explaining her backstory if you do want
to read a really awesome Elektra comic
it's kind of an origin story but it
mostly takes place in present-day with
her having you know flashbacks you know
telling the origin story that way it's
Elektra assassin it's like her version
of Dark Knight Returns which is funny
because Frank Miller wrote both of those
comics he wrote Elektra assassin right
after he wrote dark knight returns he
was like at the height of his popularity
they had this goal they wanted to kill a
new character on every single page
that's how ultraviolent the electric
comic is so if you want badass Electra
off on a road just read Electra Sasson
she did appear in the new Black Widow
comic you know it's kind of like Electra
vs black widow which sounds just
mind-blowing ly awesome but I don't
think the black widow is ever going to
appear on TV Black Widow actually
crossed paths a lot with daredevil just
because they have a lot of very similar
abilities there in their kind of both
street-level heroes even though Black
Widow is technically an Avenger it's
just that Scarlett Johansson probably
not going to appear on a TV series
anytime soon even like a prestige
Netflix series that's not like each tin
stone or anything but Captain America
Civil War shooting right now and they'll
be shooting that promoting it and doing
reshoots for pretty much all this year
while daredevil season two is filming so
the bad news is you know don't expect a
whole lot of Avengers appearing on
daredevil but i do think they'll like
they'll slowly start referencing the
Marvel Cinematic Universe more they
dropped a whole bunch of references to
the shitara invasion from the first
Avengers film in season one most of the
easter eggs though will be for daredevil
specific story lines in the comics and
everyone was totally wondering why the
Avengers Tower didn't appear in
daredevil that much mostly I think it
was from a CG perspective they just
didn't want to spend the extra money on
it they didn't want it to deal with that
now that age of Ultron has been released
and like you know the universe knows
where it is I mean they're both you know
Hell's Kitchen is like right next to
Midtown I think there'll be at least one
or two jokes about it at least about the
Avengers the other really big rumor
that's been going around lately is
defenders characters appearing in the
Marvel films and everyone wants to see
you like a cameo in Captain America
Civil War I think it's more likely that
defenders characters would appear in
Avengers infinity war in some way there
are clauses in the TV actors contracts
that allow them to appear in the films
they don't get paid extra money though
or they do get paid like very little
money the opposite is not true for the
film actors the Avengers characters
don't have any kind of clauses that
require them to go on TV so if Marvel
wanted film actors to go on the TV shows
they'd have to sign new contracts with
them and it probably crazy expensive
unless the actors waved a lot of their
fees there was actually a big Marvel
film actor that way
his contractual rights to appear in a
cameo in age of Ultron Tom Hiddleston
appeared as Loki even though the scene
was cut out he had to wave part of his
contract to make the appearance he I
mean he did it as a favor to Joss Whedon
it's not like they were paying him a
dump truck of money it's just that you
know Avengers typically have six films
in their contracts and Tom Hiddleston
was already maxed out based on the
future films that he's going to be in
those films include 43 Ragnarok you know
he's obviously going to be a big part of
that and then both Avengers infinity war
films it's always funny to hear about
you know stories with Marvel trying to
negotiate with actors for roles you know
why certain actors don't appear in
certain films but Kevin foggy actually
just announced that a couple unnamed
immediate and say who he said a couple
Avengers characters re upped their
contracts through phase 4 but of all the
Avengers in general I think that Chris
Evans will probably be the first to
leave the Avengers franchise but that's
just speculation and that won't be till
after infinity War part 2 so that's like
a long ways off so here's my big
question for you guys you know which
Marvel films do you want to see the
defenders characters appear in you know
do you think it'll happen before
Avengers infinity war what I'm probably
going to do for my next daredevil bonus
videos do like a character video like
something for Electra like electrodes
history in the comics or my favorite
Electra storylines in related TV news
they actually they've renewed agent
Carter and agents of shield so that's
pretty exciting I'll probably wait till
after agents of Shield's finale to do
some more bonus videos for that but be
sure to subscribe to get everything if
there's any you know bonus videos for
any TV or movie related stuff just leave
your requests in the comments it's going
to be a really awesome summer I'm
probably gonna start doing ant-man
videos sometime soon too so while you
guys wait for all that stuff to drop you
can click here to learn all about
Captain America Civil War there are some
age of Ultron spoilers in that video
just in case you haven't seen the movie
and you can click here for all my
daredevil videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you